[MUSIC]
I've realized I'm weird.
I'm especially weird
when it comes to food.
This is a picture of my kitchen cabinet.
It sort of looks like I'm
hosting a gathering for
chocolate fictional characters, I'm not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And no,
I'm not super prepared for Easter.
This bunny's been up here for
almost a year.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What else makes me weird?
I scrape out every last grain
of rice from a bowl I eat.
I spend extra time chopping
around the end of an onion.
And I must have smelt the milk in my
fridge at least six times this morning to
see if I could drink it,
versus having to pour it down the sink.
I wish I knew why I did all these things,
it's certainly not because I didn't
have enough to eat as a kid.
Instead, I don't know,
I feel some sort of obsessive obligation
to be mindful of the food I eat,
to respect where it came from, and
to not waste any of it unnecessarily.
To me, food is secret, which is why
when I found out about the amount of ways
that still exists, I was heart broken.
I found that the equivalent to $165
billion is thrown away in the US
every year from food that is
otherwise completely edible.
$165 billion, imagine what else
we could do with all this money.
This led me to ask, where on Earth
does all this food waste come from?
And the answer is sadly, from pretty much
everywhere, it starts in the fields.
Consumer demand may change from crop
to plantage to when they're harvested.
Which means that stores and
distributors no longer want all
the food that's been grown.
Often this can't find a new
home at short notice and
it's left to rot
unharvested in the fields.
Once harvested, food is taken
to facilities where it's sorted.
Here, estimates vary by between 20 and
50% of all produce is simply discarded
due to blemishes or being misshapen.
Now I don't know about you but
once a carrot is cut up in my salad, or
a strawberry is blended in my smoothie I
don't know, and I certainly don't care
what it started looking like.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Pausing here for just a moment,
the fact that so much of our beautiful,
fresh produce is simply thrown
away because it's ugly, not only
astounds me, but it also angers me.
Luckily, I'm not the only one who
is completely outraged by this,
and there are start-ups that will rescue
these apparently ugly vegetables from
going to the landfill, and
will send them to your door instead.
Check out imperfectproduce.com.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If you too are not judgmental about how
your mashed potatoes started looking.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Continuing on journey
through the food distribution system,
we've reached the cities where the food
is set to be sold and, hopefully, eaten.
Here some go to the restaurants and
the rest to grocery stores.
And, unsurprisingly,
food waste exists here, as well.
But this is the step where you and I,
everyday consumers,
can have a daily impact.
Lets start with restaurants, a little fun
fact to insert here is that I'm British,
and one of my favorite things about
moving to the US is the fact that
all restaurants no matter how fancy or
cheap will have to go containers.
The fact that I love to go containers and
the associated leftovers.
Really it shouldn't surprise you at this
point, as you know, I'm good with food.
But even for me there are some times and
some dishes that I just don't want
to have again, or don't eat well.
As a show of hands, how many people
have thought about taking food home from
a restaurant, but decided that they
didn't like it enough to want to bother?
And then for those of us who have brought
food home with the best intentions of
eating it, how many of you have ended up
throwing these leftovers away uneaten?
Yeah, this happens to me a bunch too.
I guess it comes with the territory of
taking pretty much everything with me.
Fundamentally, I believe that the mass
prevalence of to-go containers,
connects with one of my less favorite
things, the portion sizes in the US.
And I don't want to give the impression
that this is an issue unique to the US,
but with us millennials eating out more
often than any generation before us.
We ought to be more aware about how
much food waste we generates from
restaurant's hearty portion sizes.
Shifting now to think about
food waste in the home,
I'd like to share another
story with you all.
Not long after coming to Business School,
I decided I was going to start
snacking healthier, so
I bought a big multipack of yogurt.
Unfortunately cheap short chocolate
are always far more appealing to me than
the yogurt in my fridge.
So as the expiration date started
looming towards me, I realized,
there was no way I was going
to be able to eat it at all.
But what was I to do?
We're taught children not to accept
candy from strangers No person in my
apartment building was going to want
yogurt from the random girl down the hall.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Eventually the expiration date passed
and I begrudgingly picked up
the yogurt that was left and
fringed at the thump it made when
it hit the bottom of my trash can.
Now I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say that most of you all most likely have
had experience throwing away food
that's not too dissimilar to this.
But I'd like to remind to the part of my
story where I thought it be too weird to
give the yogurt away.
Why is that so weird?
That shouldn't be weird,
and as it happens,
a lot of people don't
think it actually is.
There's a startup, OYO, that facilitates
peer-to-peer sharing of food.
At this type,
they've shared over 400,000 food items,
and have an exception
marketplace clearance rate.
What this means is that
people want free food, and
they're prepared to accept
it even from a stranger.
The issue that OYO has found is as much as
we're prepared to accept food, we tend not
to think of food that we no longer want
as something that others may still value.
What I realize we need to do is
refrain the concept of sharing food.
We live in a sharing economy, we share
apartments with strangers through Airbnb.
We share our cars with others
through Uber and Lyft.
Why not share our leftover or
unwanted food with neighbors and friends?
The second thing we need to do is be more
honest with ourselves about how much
food waste we actually generate and
how we can be a part of the solution.
No one like to thing that
they're a problematic waster.
And it's much easier to think that
the issue of food waste is so
big that there's nothing we can
do as individuals to impact it.
But I'd like to challenge this concept.
I'd like you to think about the other
issues that seem too big for
individual action to matter.
Recycling, energy consumption and climate
change, even civil rights movements.
Yes, there is more that we can
do in each of these areas, but
we've seen the cultural shifts that
have happened surrounding them.
And they all started with individual
actions that combined have been effective.
What I hope to leave you all with
today is a greater understanding for
the food distribution system, and the
associated waste that goes along with it.
I hope I have given you
insights to make you pause,
appreciate the food you
have a little more and
perhaps think about ways that you
can reduce your own food waste.
Maybe, just maybe I have
persuaded some of you to
stop being as weird with food as I am.
Join me, let's all be weird together and
make weird the new normal.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]